Some things are really complicated in the
world and in politics.
And they require deep knowledge.
They require speaking to experts.
They require understanding different disciplines
and considering a lot of different components
nuclear energy, string theory, postmodernism,
whatever.
I think you understand the right amount of
taxation to balance, not properly funding
social programs while not disincentive ising
work or whatever.
Right.
There's there's a lot of complicated stuff
that exists in life.
We have a really simple grand theory in front
of us which explains Donald Trump's behavior
as of late.
And it doesn't require this deep and and nuanced
knowledge of anything like string theory or
taxation.
He is terrified that people that you I'm talking
about, people like you are going to vote in
November.
And more specifically, he's terrified that
you are going to vote for someone other than
him.
If you just look at the last two, three weeks
in American politics, just about everything
that Donald Trump has done publicly relates
to that fear, which has become an existential
fear for him because his political life depends
on how you vote in November.
Don't imagine that.
It's about how other people vote.
It's about how you vote.
You have agency in this and Donald Trump is
scared to death.
His political life that you might vote for
somebody else.
Donald Trump demoting his campaign manager,
Brad Parr scale because he saw he was losing
in the polls and he reportedly was on the
phone furious with PA scale and ultimately
par scale is demoted.
That is because Donald Trump is scared that
he's going to lose if Brad Paşa Scale sticks
in as his campaign manager.
Donald Trump's new tone on Corona virus, which
lasted like three days, which included, you
know, carrying around his mask and saying
it could get worse before it gets better,
a more sort of somber, sober tone.
It was just desperation to turn polling around.
His idea was, let's just ignore it, ignore
it, ignore it, open up, pretend everything's
going back to normal.
That failed.
He knows that the failure on coronaviruses,
one of the main drags on his approval rating.
And so he takes a new tone.
That's all it is.
And it only lasted about three days.
Trump opposing vote by mail because he thinks
vote by mail will hurt his reelection.
And it will.
I'm going to show you the new polling data
on that Trump correctly perceives.
If more people vote by mail, that's probably
not good for me.
It's good for Joe Biden.
He's right.
I will explain why.
So Trump's motivation to stop vote by mail.
By which we really just mean expanding absentee
about absentee ballot access.
His real motivation is not, oh, it's going
to be fraudulent or fraudulent, as he says.
It's that it's just not going to be good for
him.
Announcing that he's banning Tick-Tock could
even relate to this.
Now, will he ban?
Tick tock.
We don't know.
You know, like like most things, we were supposed
to get a new health care plan yesterday.
We didn't get it.
He announces many things that never happen.
Comedian Sarah Cooper's videos about Donald
Trump go Gigha viral on Tick-Tock.
And they really don't make Trump look good.
It was tick tock users that allegedly organized
that coordinated mass ticket request for Trump's
Tulsa rally, which ended up with a two thirds
empty arena.
So, again, going after Tick-Tock could be
trying to look strong on China.
It also could be that Trump perceives that
it's going to help him in terms of his election
to ban tick tock kneecapping the post office
by putting in his multi huge millionaire donor
as the postmaster general.
If people are going to be voting by mail,
delay the delivery of the ballots by hurting
the post office.
Perfect strategy, right?
Every action is in the context of how can
Trump get himself reelected, reportedly being
open to help from Russia, China and either
other countries.
And we'll talk about that later today.
There's a new interview there which is completely
out of hand.
It's because Trump is desperate that he's
going to lose and he'll take anybody's help
that he can get.
And then in the end, as Trump realizes that
some people are truly so committed to his
removal that they would crawl over broken
glass and dodge landmines to vote to remove
Donald Trump.
He floated the idea last week of delaying
the election.
Now, I have to tell you, I wish I was as confident
that Trump was going to lose as Trump seems
to be, that he's going to lose in the sense
that you would only do all the things Donald
Trump is doing if you were pretty reasonably
sure that you had a good shot at losing this
thing.
So while publicly Trump says we're doing great
in Florida, we're doing great in Florida.
Both of them, et cetera.
He knows that really he's not doing well and
he knows that he may well lose.
And I am not as confident as Trump seems to
be that he is going to lose.
Over the last seven days, some polls have
tightened up in Trump's favor.
Now it's he still behind.
But it's it's still, you know, five weeks
to the elect.
I'm sorry.
Now know we're still two months, three months
to the election.
I'm getting confused.
We're four and a half weeks from the first
ballots being cast, but we're still almost
three months from the election, three months
to the day.
You don't want to see polls start to tighten.
Now, that's a bad sign.
Now, everybody has a different idea about
what drives Donald Trump.
And I got some emails over the weekend saying,
you know, Trump's worried that if he loses
in November, he's going to end up in prison.
I actually don't think that he's worried about
that because I don't think there's really
any chance that it's going to happen.
And I know that I continue to hear from people
who say Trump's going to get indicted for
this.
Trump is going to get indicted for that.
I don't think so.
I think that there will be some financial
crimes for which his companies maybe will
be held held accountable with fines.
But Trump's not going to prison and anybody
waiting for that, I think is going to be waiting
for the rest of their lives.
This is simply about Donald Trump's narcissism.
Donald Trump's Trump's delusions of grandeur
and the constant power trip that he is on.
He doesn't see himself as a loser.
And losing is, you know, to use their language.
Losing is a Beda.
I don't think Trump in practice even wants
to be president.
He wants to be president in theory in terms
of the power that comes with being the president
of the United States.
Trump is a cornered animal who perceives a
threat.
Right now.
He has the fight response rather than the
flight response.
The flight response might be.
I'm going resign or turn things over to Mike
Pence or whatever before this goes bad in
November, if indeed that's what's going to
happen.
Trump has the fight response, and we know
from studying the animal kingdom that this
is dangerous territory to be in.
All of his actions from now until November
should really be interpreted under this framework
and we just can't let him do it.
It's actually that important.
And the numbers that we now have relating
to vote by mail versus vote in person are
a huge signal about why.
On that issue, Trump is digging his feet in
the ground, sticking his head in the sand,
drawing a line in the sand.
Whatever metaphor or analogy I'm mixing up
here, you all know what I'm talking about.
And opposing vote by mail.
Let's talk about that next